we'll get five suggestions then we'll
drop a beat to a freestyle rap if you
are sat over here what would you like a
rap about
chess oh [ __ ] [ __ ] okay sorry I thought
you said chess Lounge I was like that
sounds like a [ __ ] banging night out
let's go to the chess Lounge but what
you said you you pronounce shares long
differently to me so you mean like so
you said chess Lounge but you mean the
chair that you lie on right
yeah I'm not being weird like is it
anyone French it says long right how do
you pronounce it
okay cool okay cool good thank you chess
long it took a long time to get to a
pretty basic suggestion so the rest of
you bear that in mind people sat over
here what you want to rap about
Neanderthal DNA yes look at that
fantastic stuff thank you very much
Neanderthal DNA middle of the room what
you're wrapped about
whole milk so long they Shred the sheets
that is a suggestion wrought from
hard-won life experience
I really feel like you're calling out a
partner or ex-partner there
cheslong
Neanderthal DNA big feet with toenails
so long they Shred the sheets but uh but
you still stay with them because big b
equals
I don't know big shoes in it right so
people are over here what would you like
a rap about
an F1 Podium the the podium in a Formula
One race where you stand three two or
one right that's yeah foreign
he's not being sexist there are no
female F1 drivers it's just it's just a
fact right
um final suggestion from this this kind
of shady Enclave what would you like to
wrap about
daddy Lumberjack oh yes
for those of you that cannot see him
this is the the big Burly man with you
you look look you don't wear a shirt
like that have arms that big and facial
hair that neat and go oh please don't
rap about me
foreign
people at the back are saying stand up
uh he's way too drunk yeah Daddy
Lumberjack oh yeah
thank you Dad all right this is my show
daddy Lumberjack F1 Podium big feet with
toenail Salon they Shred the sheets
cheslong and Neanderthal DNA cool this
is the freestyle that's right made up on
the spot base and all those things don't
worry we'll be a [ __ ] if you're
expecting it to be and my band's gonna
play me they're gonna make him a beat so
let's hear it and then let's uh wrap
over it
foreign
[Music]
it's
fat with a pH it's thoroughly enjoyable
[Music]
no lines no bath no pen no idea what I
say back in the day looking at the DNA
Watson and Crick they gave it a tick
inventing it maybe observing it let me
enter in like a cave going thousands
years ago people see the sapiens come a
homo but these guys different yes you
all see them in the museum whole Natural
History Neanderthal how do you know if
you've got it kids your head extended
cro Magnum Ridge that's the brow line
looking like wow prowl line in Germany
and actually how that's the region over
there I won't insult it European
neanderthals around all the baltics I
actually did archeology degree that's
why I got so much knowledge coming from
me and people today got the DNA back in
the day they didn't do it this way did
Neanderthals sing when they buried the
dead okay I've got a lot of essays
stored in my head about this so we'll
move along to the song Let Me recline on
the
[Music]
with me we get to know each other
intimately sexually and maybe I could
inspect your feet if they're too small
we won't get it on I want your little
peer ever so long so wrong craycon yes
he never fail I like it when I see a
female toenail much longer than average
strong like a sandwich with brie do you
want to come to bed with me
careful that you do not be tear in the
sheets I need to get them a large amount
you'll be tearing through even though a
high thread counts you idiot yes you
ripped it from Egypt cottoning off I'll
move back cause we need it to change the
accent I'm frozen spraying champagne
like I'm on the podium call me Max
verstappen or Lewis Hamilton I'm not a
fan of the staff and I'd be [ __ ] not
rapping he means winning all of the
things in Suzuka that's the Japanese
race tomorrow I'll give some truth there
standing on the number one two is
slightly lower and number three they
shake the champagne the bottles blower
spraying all around it's very exciting
they hang out the flags they play all
the little National and thems and now a
turn to my right best of men with the
largest right arms you could be my
friend come over here stand with me come
on up here be The Lumberjack Debbie take
my hands because you look slightly drunk
oh your palms are sweaty such a handsome
hunt I'm just doing this I'm like we're
having a ball you might be girthy but
actually I'm slightly more tall and how
it's the side of your feet go if you
take him to bed when you get home do you
give them a clip and then you give me
that grin under the mustache long
toenails of keratin let's look at this
ring it's ever so nice I quiz it it's
quite expensive looking just like a
Signet I know you kick ass where the
Ring of your class that's a lumberjack
daddy with a lovely mustache
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]